learning is growing and we not only
decided to grow together in life but
learn and succeed together as well I
successfully switched my career to full
stack Java domain with
in salary hike and I was able to grab
new opportunities in my current
organization and also receive a 10
salary hike hey I am swamijit Basu I am
a senior QA engineer at Encore Inc and I
am show me and I work as a senior
quality Analyst at doodleblue Innovation
we started our upskilling journey
together which simply learned and
certainly we made the right choice after
our marriage I had to relocate to
Bangalore and take a year Gap after
working for five years but I decided to
restart my career again and make a
switch to software domain so I enrolled
myself in full stack Java developer
program from Simply learn seeing my
wife's passion for learning every day
inspired me to take up a course on
simply learn as well I've always been
passionate about technology and learning
devops was always in my bucket list when
I saw simply learns collaboration with
Caltech ctme I decided to take a course
on PG devops after the course I not only
switched my career to full stack Java
development with a 15 increment in the
salary but now also I can work from home
since it's a software domain and being
the new mom that's the best thing one
could ask for to spend time with little
one during these early years
for me learning devops was fun and
fulfilling at the same time earlier I
had to rely on others at work but after
upskilling myself I single-handedly can
set up the entire blueprint on my code
base alone and get the desired output
and because of that I could grab new
projects in my organization with a 10
percent salary high we enrolled to
upskill ourselves when we were expecting
our first child so upscaling Journey
with simply learn would be undoubtedly
very special to both of us while doing
the course we did come across a lot of
challenges due to the pregnancy but my
wife showed me was a great inspiration
for me as she was handling it all
together and she kept motivating and
inspiring me all the way moreover the
recorded classes and the weekend class
helped us maintain the balance between
work and learning apart from work we
love to spend time with our little one
learning with simply Learned was quite a
fulfilling experience for both of us we
believe that grow doesn't happen
overnight rather it's a journey of
several all steps and upskilling is one
of them